so I'm glad to be here to talk about
designing great progressive work
so I'm gonna start with a question have
you noticed that the mobile web doesn't
really feel good anymore there are lots
of problems on the mobile web lagging
issues performance issues so let's see
the mobile web problems are nowadays
being slow because the average load on
mobile website is 19 seconds and that's
a lot on 3G networks also have you
noticed that this crawling on mobile web
is always unresponsive it's lagging it
always needs a few more seconds to feel
your touch on the mobile screen now also
the content jumps a lot on a mobile web
when it loads you scroll too fast and
the website is still loading you see
things jumping and also if you open a
website and you click on the button by
mistake and then you have to wait for
like 19 seconds and then go back in
order for you to see the previous page
so you don't really feel in control on
the mobile web but I'm here today to
tell you that the web can feel good and
not just good but great with progressive
web apps I always wanted to use this
effect so let me introduce myself I'm
Nicole and I mean UI UX designer and I'm
also a design teacher at Logan which is
a coding bootcamp that teaches web
development in 9 weeks
so let me refresh your memory is a bit
what makes an app a PWA what are the
qualifications for an app to be a
progressive wobba so first a progressive
web app is fast because it loads quickly
and performs smoothly throughout the
whole user experience that's because of
service workers and the best practices
for performance a PWA is progressive
because it works everywhere and it's
supercharged and modern browsers so you
can enhance the user experience for
devices that support more advanced
features hence the term progressive
enhancement a progressive web app is
also connectivity independent so it
works offline and it works with low
internet connections and a PWA is
engaging users are more likely to use a
waa again more than normal website and
that's because you could add it to the
home screen and there's push
notifications and there are lots of
increased conversions and engagement
because of pre lwas
example 5 - shoppers spend now 20% more
time on the current PWA than they did on
the previous one and the Weather Channel
saw an 80 percent improvement in the
after shipping pwace so now how can we
design great progressive web apps
so let me categorize the best practices
for progressive web app in 3 a
progressive web app have to be app like
it has to have an app like experience so
how can we make something that looks
like a native app but it's not really a
native app also it should be engaging so
it should have a great experience and
should engage the users back to the app
and it should be resilient should have a
reliable performance so throughout this
talk I'm gonna give you some UX and
technical recommendations to make great
progressive web apps so let's start with
the first one how can we make something
progressive web app that has an app like
experience because our progressive web
app should meet the users expectations
as it's as if it's a native app and we
have a common tendency to design web
like components for for web apps usually
and that's what we shouldn't do so the
first thing we should do is start by
taking some UX inspiration from native
apps instead of websites so this is in
order to match the users mental models
and use more applied designs and
components so what I usually do I browse
sites like patterns that come for design
inspiration and patterns com is a
website for inspiration for mobile
design apps another thing I also do is
level up my familiarity with material
design because since the user expects
the design and interaction to look like
a native app then we should be aware of
material design and material design
system like interactions and colors and
principles of material design
so you could do that at material that I
Oh another thing you can do is also use
material design components MDC is a
modular and customer customizable UI
components library so in this library
you could use ripple animations cards
buttons grids everything that has to do
with a native app on Android another
thing we can do to make it look like a
native app or have an app like
experience is to make sure our app icon
looks good because the app icon is gonna
be on the home screen of the user it
will sit next to the other native apps
so it should be it should visually match
the other icons so your app icon should
visually match the native app icons some
I can some phones have like visual
standards that it should match in terms
of size in terms of colors and what we
can do is also create a responsive icon
that can work in different sizes so what
do I mean by responsive I mean it should
be simple enough and has no details no
words it's very simple and a unique
shape that can work on all sizes sizes
even if it's a very very small size
because your icon is going to be on the
splash screen on the task switcher
inside notification banners the app
install banner and all of that and also
this app icons should be great on all
platforms because every platform since
our PWA is going to be used on all
platforms then every platform has some
specific requirements so as you can see
here there's each eye can look very
different on every platform and for
example on iOS the icons can not be
transparent and acquire a background
color and if you don't add a background
color they will add the background color
for you like this one in black so make
sure to test that and the best way to
see all this is to use real favicon
generator or any generator for favicons
so here you can see all of the
variations in one go and lets you make
adjustments for every platform and then
it generates the manifesto Jason
so another thing we can do to make our
app a more like a native app is also
brand our app using the theme color so
the theme color is a great way to give
our app a brand and uniqueness for it
and feel native with that but there are
two types of theme colors the first one
is the browser theme color the theme
color this is the theme color that we
see when we open the app from a browser
so it's independent from the other
manifest app manifest so here we could
use the primary color the accent color
whatever works with our app and this is
the one you see on the nav bar on top
and this is how we do it we add a meta
name theme color and the color in the
the value of the content the second one
is the app theme color so this is the
one that color's the status bar and the
header when accessing via homescreen so
after the user adds your app to the home
screen then when they open it from the
home screen this is the color they see
so as you can see the status bar is also
colored and even it shows in the task
switcher and this is how we do that we
add the theme color to the app manifest
will add the theme color and the color
value
now another thing to consider to meet
the users expectations since we're doing
a progressive web app it can also work
on desktop and laptops so it doesn't
always have to be just for mobile so
that's desktop and laptop a curse queens
are always an extra step that I think we
should take the perfect example of this
is out web they have a progressive web
app that also works everywhere else on
bigger screens and the nice thing is
that it looks exactly like the other
progressive web app on mobile but it's
just bigger so now let's talk about how
we can make progressive web app that is
more engaging so we need to make sure
that we are responsive to the users
input to promote feedback and engagement
so the first thing we need to do is to
give immediate visual feedback whenever
the user interacts with the app and
that's how we make it look native so the
first thing we need to know is that we
need to consider the best and worst tap
areas on mobile because after a lot of
studies we realized that actually the
best eye area on on the phone is the one
in the middle
the worst one is the top left and the
bottom right we're bottom left top right
so you could also test your app and see
which one works for you and for your
users
but it's good to know and good to
consider and also always give immediate
visual feedback try to respond to the
users immediately in 100 and under 100
milliseconds even even if the transition
that you're doing is more than 100
milliseconds try to start responding in
100 milliseconds also maintain a minimum
touch target size of 48 DP which means
density-independent pixels and this is
what material design recommends this is
because if the users touches something
and it doesn't interact
it means might be too small and this
leads to frustration and confusion and
we don't want that and others too so
this is to ensure balanced information
density and usability the app install
banner is a great way to increase
engagement for progressive web apps
so it has the ability to have your users
quickly and seamlessly add your app to
the home screen but not a lot of people
actually see this or accept this when
they see the app install banner because
users are not really familiar with what
a progressive web app is yet it's still
a very new thing and normal users are
not really technical so what we need to
do is we need to guide users and tell
them that there's something called
adding to homescreen so what we can do
is we can add like a subtle signifier
and this is what the flip card does as
you can see here there is a plus button
and it vibrates a bit so you tap on it
and they show you that you could add a
flip car to the home screen by tapping
on this overflow menu now make sure to
test this on all your browsers because
the sometimes the overflow menu is
different on each browser the position
of it and what we can do also if if the
user downloads the app or installs it to
the home screen we can hide this plus
button so so it doesn't really be very
annoying to the user it's showing every
time so we can do that by hiding it when
the app is standalone so we add a media
query this playmode standalone and when
it's standalone then we display the
button as none what we can do also is
that we can delay the app install banner
until after the user engages with your
app so this is also a nice way to do it
since we cannot really control when to
show this app install banner we can at
least delay it and this is also what
they do in Flipkart after you go and buy
a product then they show you the Add to
Home screen and that because they know
that we like this off now so add us to
your home screen so but it's a bit more
subtle and less annoying and also soon
we'll be able to control this as app
install banner so notifications are also
a great way to reengage the user back
toward the app because of service
workers and so what we can do is first
don't break the user's flow for an
update so if you have an update don't
really
so a push notification for it what you
can do is you could show a snack bar for
example on the top get the latest
improvements and just tap to refresh so
this is a nicer way that doesn't really
disrupt the users experience and also if
you want to do a push notification there
are some guidelines for it or just some
tips first notification should be
personal it should be timely it should
be relevant also to the user actionable
if you can add more actions to it or
just a call to action and it could
should work offline on a progressive web
app so tried not to annoy users or spam
them with push notifications only send
notifications when it's very important
and when it meets these qualifications
and what we can do also is that we can
give users control over their push
notifications so an out web you could
toggle push notifications on and off
from the sidebar and this is a nice way
to give the user control on our app now
asking for permissions can be tricky a
bit
we need sometimes we need to ask for a
location for the contact for the camera
but we need to make sure that we're not
disrupting the users experience for
example don't ask for permission on the
first visit as information on the first
visit of a website can be really
annoying because doesn't have any
context why would the user accept this
doesn't really explain why and it can
confuse users because you didn't really
earn the trust yet on the first
permission on the first visit and also
don't use fake Android native banners I
noticed that on Alibaba on the
progressive web app this is the native
one but the one before it is actually a
fake one it looks the same but it just
has smaller and you tap on next and then
they will show you the real one and what
you can do is ask for permission when
it's relevant
so in snap what PWA after you go to use
my camera and then they will show you
but not the asking for permission banner
so it's more a respectful way it's
relevant and it makes sense only when
the user wants to
do that then we asked the user for
permission now in progressive Web Apps
if the user installs the app to their
home screen it means there's no URL bar
on the top because most of the time the
progressive web app will be standalone
so that's why we need to think about how
we can provide an easy way to share now
luckily there's the web share API but
it's coming soon in the next chrome and
what what it does is that it's a native
picker so I have to click on on share it
opens the native picker where you could
choose the new one of the native apps
that you have to share with but this is
coming soon so what we can do now is we
could implement a share button that
allows us allows the users to copy that
URL to the clipboard so this is a nice
way to do it or share with the social
media platform too now since we're
talking about engagement and interaction
it's worth noting that the burger menu
that you might be using might be hurting
your user experience
let's see why now even though the burger
menu looks cleaner because it hides away
some things but it's kind of out of
sight because the user has to have an
extra click he has to click first so it
has a lower discoverability it's less
efficient we kept because he has to
click first and then see what options he
has and sometimes the back button will
be reserved to the menu because on iOS
we don't really have the the hardware
back button so they have to be reserved
for it or just move the burger the
burger menu and add the back button
there so here are some suggestions what
we can do is that we could use tabs so
this is a very common pattern that we
all use and we could either use the
icons or icons with tabs with labels on
the top on the bottom and now of course
some of you might be saying what if I
have more than 5 sections well if you
have more section more than 5 sections
what we can do is add a more button or
the three points like a menu so
prioritize the five main sections
them out there and everything else could
go into more so this is a better way
because everything is just out there in
front of the user now sometimes a burger
menu can make sense for example like an
uber and uber everything is provided on
the main screen everything the user
needs is there only when the user needs
secondary screens like history options
settings all of that then they do they
go into the burger menu so in this
scenario it does make sense to use a
burger menu now let's talk about how we
could make resilient progressiva bars
first we need to know that the app
should feel local and that's how we can
make it look native the app should be so
fast that it doesn't it shouldn't load
at all it should be it should feel local
and 53 percent of mobile users abandon
sites that take longer than three
seconds to load so that's how users are
so impatient nowadays and so distracted
and they want everything right now so
let's see these two examples now let's
look at the first loading the normal one
when you open a website usually in most
cases you open it and then you wait on a
white screen then you wait a little more
and then everything loads at the same
time now the other type of loading is
you tap enter and then immediately you
start seeing components loading after
the other so the other one the
progressive loading is is actually more
comfortable for the user because it
reduces the users uncertainty because
they start seeing things immediately and
it reduces the perception of time and
that's a great thing so to do that we
should use the actual model the app
shell is the minimal HTML CSS and
JavaScript that powers a user interface
so let's see some examples
this is Twitter lights app shell for
example they have the nav bar they have
the main action button and this is also
Google inbox app shell this can work on
all types of sizes not just for mobile
phones and this is out web app show that
we just saw in action
so as you can see we have some common
components that we use for app shells
for example we have the navbar we have
the tab bar if you have at a bar or a
burger menu then we have the side bar
the background color if you have it and
a loader and the main action if you have
that so these are kind of the common
components where you could create an app
shot from it now it could be less than
that it could be a bit more than that
but try to always keep these types of
components for an app shell now what we
can do to also make a faster instant
first load is that we could inline some
of our SVG icons if you're using icons
then the the best way to use an icon is
from an SVG instead of PNG because it's
the lightest way but how can we make it
even better we could inline them now why
do I say some of because if we inline
only the SVG icons above the fold that
the icons that the user sees immediately
then it's great but if we do that for
all our files then our HTML file will be
so huge which will defeat the purpose so
we need to make sure that we inline only
the important ones the ones the the user
see is at the first second now fonts are
one of the most common reasons of a slow
first load and we know that but being a
designer I love typography I love using
fonts but I have to limit them sometimes
and it's worth noting that for
progressive web apps it kind of makes
sense to use device fonts because web
fonts are heavy but device fonts are
weightless so what do I mean by device
ones I don't mean use Arial or comic
sense or a vatika I mean whatever there
is a way to tweak the map to tweak the
operating system so what if there's a
way to tweak the font to match the
operating system for example to use
Roboto on Android and San Francisco and
I guess it depends on the operating
system actually we can do that so we
could add all the funds of the devices
possible
after the other so we stack them one
after the other the other and let's say
here the user is using an Android then
the browser will lead Roboto and just
ignore everything else so that's a great
way to actually show the Vice ones
because the user will feel like home if
they're using a progressive web app that
is using their device phones of their
operating system so here these are the
four backs for each one the apple system
is the San Francisco for Safari and my
on Mac and blink Mac system is the San
Francisco and chrome and the list goes
on so this is how it looks like actually
medium does this medium they use also
the device phones that I just showed you
and here as you can see on iOS they use
San Francisco because it's it reads it
on San Francisco and Roboto on Android
now if you're using custom fonts or web
fonts it's great if we could preload
them so how can we do that
first this is the normal scenario this
is where the font files will only start
downloading after the CSS finishes as
you can see that's not really good so
what we could do is we preload them we
add a link rel preload with a href of
Roboto for example as font and other
type as rough too it's important to add
the cross origin this is to avoid double
requests so this is what we get as you
can see now the fonts load
simultaneously with the CSS and HTML
file and this avoids the flash of
unstyled content now designing for the
offline experience is a very important
part of a progressive web app and not
just if it's offline but also if it has
a lower internet connection and you
might think that there's not really low
internet connections but I come from
Lebanon and in Lebanon the internet
connection is really bad like it's one
megabyte per second so there are lots of
factors of a bad network connection it
could be poor coverage of a provider for
example it could be extreme weather
conditions if there's a
stone for example the internet
connection could just go for like
minutes or hours sometimes it could be
power outages and it could also be
traveling into dead zones and this could
happen anywhere if we're traveling to
the Metro sometimes the internet doesn't
really work there so your goal is to
provide a good experience that lessens
the impact of this internet connection
so here are some tips what we could do
first is with clearly inform the user
when a change in state occurs and we do
that as soon as possible so inform the
user what actions they can do when the
internet is offline so in this example
you seem to have a bad network
connection but don't worry the messages
will be sent when the Internet is back
online and when the Internet is back
online some apps require auto updating
for example the weather because the
weather has data that you need that are
very updated so the weather doesn't
really work if it has all data so
because of that we need to auto update
here now how you deal with them forming
the users that the internet is back
online will depend on your app in this
example for example inform the user that
there's newer content with a tag to
refresh if you're reading an article on
a news website and you're scrolling
through it it doesn't really make sense
to refresh automatically it's better to
tap to refresh because you would lose
where you were leading we were reading
last and also you could provide an
offline experience by default if your
app doesn't require much data then you
could cache that data or some of that
data by default and try to make this
experience as stable as possible and in
this example if I think that the network
is down these sections are available to
read but these other sections are
partially available for example and if
your data is heavy you could provide a
data saver mode and this is what Twitter
light does they have a data saver mode
which which you could toggle on and off
from the settings and as you can see the
images and videos are all they're not
loaded yet until you load them and this
you reduce the data usage but up to 70%
and that's a lot
we could also give the user control to
download something for offline news and
this makes sense for videos for example
because videos are heavy you could
download them and see them later on in
the offline section so this example is
Biograph put PWA
where you could make available offline
for any video and also inform the user
when the app is ready for offline
consumption and make sure the language
you're using for this fits your audience
for example caching complete future
visits will work offline is good but
serviceworker installed for example does
not really work for normal users and
also give an offline mode color to your
theme it really really looks nice if you
have an offline theme for example if
everything is red or everything is blue
and when it's offline you could just
give it a grey color for that so it
looks really nice
just with color we could tell the user
that you're offline so an applet lessens
the impact of a network failure will
feel magical to the user now I'm going
to talk about more other design
considerations for example iOS iOS
doesn't fully support progressive web
apps it doesn't support service workers
push notifications installing to home
screen but the good news is that they're
working on it actually and that's great
news Apple is finally working on service
workers so it's in development but
meanwhile we should do something so what
we first do we could work on the item
title so the icon title since the iOS
ignores the manifest.json by default the
title tag is used from the HTML so what
we can do is to update it we could add
Apple mobile web app title to update it
also the app icon on iOS is a screenshot
by default I'm not sure why they do that
so what we should do is that we should
change that specify a web app icon
so Apple touch icon what we can do also
is that we could hide Safari UI
components so this is the Apple mobile
web app capable but we need to make sure
we test our app because this is a very
dangerous and powerful meta tag and this
is why first iOS doesn't have a hard
wait back button we know that which
means if you open a website PWA and
enter a page that doesn't have a back
button then you're stuck there forever
so we need to make sure to test this or
add back button and also some links open
in the browser and a PWA on iOS for
example if we enter this from the home
screen and we scroll down and enter one
it goes away from the progressive web
app and that's just really an awful
experience so here are some solutions we
get the first solution is that we could
add a back navigation on all the screens
on the PWA and we could use the location
that it's ref instead of the a links for
internet navigation or the second
solution would be to just remove the web
app capable meta tag
so keep the icon and meta for the title
but just don't let it open in
full-screen mode and this is what
Twitter light does on iOS so they have
an epi wau open from the home screen but
it opens with the browser all on the top
so this is for now at least if you want
to use the web app capable you would
also change the status bar appearance so
here we have like three types of status
bar colors there are some consideration
for this this is the first one which is
content default it's white the second
one is black and the third one is black
translucent and the black translucent
the the content floats on top of the
full screen content the status bar so
instead of pushing it down it just
floats there so you might have to push
your content accordingly but although
everything on iOS is not really working
the best way a lot of companies actually
has a lot of increasing in conversions
for example Aliexpress so on 82%
increase
on iOS conversion after building
progressive web app and also the
Washington Post has seen a new five-time
increase in user engagement on iOS and
also with the Washington Post mixed a
progressive web app with an amp
experience and here we have the
difference between the instant mobile
web and the current high web so it's
allowed to offer a game-changing
experience now let's talk a bit about
accessibility since we're doing a
progressive web app it means it works
everywhere and why not make it work for
everyone too so designing for
accessibility might be a challenge and
we tend to forget or just skip it
as not being important but actually 49
million people suffer from disabilities
and not just permanent disabilities but
it could be anything from broken arm
from the train being too shaky or
anything so accessibility refers to the
experience of a web app that works
anywhere for everyone and if you design
inclusively your design for everyone so
try to always be aware of global
accessibility fork of color blind people
or flow and devices to of also countries
with expensive data and try to always
design inclusively and try to always be
globally relevant using icons and
languages because sometimes the user
that may be using your app doesn't
really understand advanced English for
example so what we could do is use
simple global English language and will
always be culturally relevant so use a
friendly language for uneducated people
and use more icons and fewer words also
consider high data cost and low end
phones because some countries have very
very expensive data make sure to always
reduce the app size and we're already
doing that with progressive web apps but
make sure to keep this in mind and also
consider small screen sizes because some
people are still using very old phones
we need to make sure that we're
minimizing the battery usage too and
also we could let the users know about
data sizes whenever we have heavy
if you want to test lower small screen
sizes you could test that at material
desire of slash devices also make better
color choices since your PWA is going to
be used anywhere it could be used
outdoor too and people with low vision
have haven't don't really have good
vision and outdoor uses so make sure
you're using sufficient contrast you
could also use color blind simulation
filters you could test the colors for
colorblind people on material that io /
color what we can do also is to
implement techniques for an accessible
website and there's a great checklist
for accessibility on this link web AI m
dot org so remember that some users will
be using screen readers on on for
example and try to work on the focus
elements on text alternatives images and
adding labels and inputs and all of that
so i'm going to end this talk with it's
just a question should i design
separately for ios and android the user
that usually what makes sense is that
you design just one that works anywhere
but actually some progressive web apps
are doing both for example barcelona
city app they used design for iOS and
for Android as a progressive web app so
it really depends on what you need what
your users need now the takeaway of this
talk would be first to take inspiration
from native apps try to always think
like you're doing something as a native
app instead of a website that's on the
crappiest devices that you could find
using remote debugging and apply
checklist just like this one you just
saw and from that you can truly build
amazing experiences on the web if you
want to know more on progressive web app
and on UX tips the best way to see this
is on Google web fundamentals on these
two links
and I hope you enjoy the talk and let me
know if you have any questions also make
sure to follow me on Twitter thank you
[Applause]